-Hey, Jimmy, quick question.
What do you know about
Puerto Rico?
-Puerto Rico? Not much.
I mean, I know it's
an unincorporated territory
of the United States, about
1,000 miles southeast of Miami.
And I know it's known locally
as Borinquen,
from the indigenous Taino name
Borinken,
meaning
"land of the valiant Lord."
Oh, and it was
colonized by Spain in 1493
after the arrival of Columbus,
and remained in
Spanish possession
for the next four centuries.
And the U.S. acquired it in 1898
after the Spanish-American War
under the terms of
the Treaty of Paris.
And its political status
has been a matter of
public debate ever since.
-Okay, but --
-Oh, and its chief exports
include rum and electronics
and pharmaceuticals
and chemicals
and medical equipment.
I can't believe
I forgot medical equipment,
and, of course, canned tuna.
Other than that, I don't know
much about Puerto Rico.
Why?
-"Hamilton" is playing in
Puerto Rico and we got tickets.
Want to come?
-Wepa!
♪♪♪♪
-From the beautiful island of
Puerto Rico,
it's "The Tonight Show"
starring Jimmy Fallon!
Tonight, join Jimmy and his
guests Lin-Manuel Miranda,
the cast of "Hamilton,"
Bad Bunny, Chef Jose Andres,
and music from
Jose Feliciano and Ozuna.
And now here's your host --
Jimmy Fallon!
-Hola, everyone. We're here.
We are so excited to be
doing "The Tonight Show"
from the beautiful island of
Puerto Rico.
Even just walking around,
you can feel the energy
and the spirit of this place.
The history, the food,
the music, the people,
Puerto Rico is thriving,
and it's open for business.
And what better way to show it
than Lin-Manuel Miranda
taking his whole team on
the road and bringing "Hamilton"
to Puerto Rico
for the very first time?
They're supporting the arts.
They're raising money
for the island,
and they're celebrating
all the amazing things
Puerto Rico has to offer.
And when we heard that Lin was
doing that, we were like,
"We're coming down too,
and we're ready to party."
So now we're here.
We're in San Juan.
We're outside
the "Hamilton" theater.
I was gonna go watch the show,
but then I thought to myself,
"Why just watch 'Hamilton'
when I can actually
be in 'Hamilton?'" Here we go.